- Okay. Hi, I am Debbie Coen.
I chair the Terry
Lectures Committee as well
as the Program and History
of Science and Medicine here.
Last year, the Terry Committee
launched a new series,
the Terry Forums in order
to bring together scholars
and students from across
the campus to reflect
on questions about
ethical knowledge making
that cut across the disciplines.
The forum is intended to be a space
where we can learn from
each other in a spirit
of mutual respect for our differences.
Our speaker today, I am delighted
to say is Charmaine Royal.
As you can see here,
she is the Robert O.
Keohane Professor of African
and African American Studies, Biology,
Global Health and Family
Medicine & Community Health.
And as she put it at lunch,
she is all about interdisciplinarity
as that mouthful suggests.
As I also learned at lunch today,
Professor Royal grew up in Jamaica wanting
to become a physician,
came to the us for college
to Howard University
and took her first genetics course
and became fascinated by the subject
though the questions that
seemed most pressing to her,
even back then questions
about the science's ethical framework
and its entanglement with racism didn't
yet have a clear disciplinary home.
And ever since she has
been at the forefront
of crafting new methods and networks
to pursue those questions.
She went on to earn a master's
degree in genetic counseling
and a doctorate in human
genetics from Howard
then completed postgraduate training
in ethical legal and social implications,
research and bioethics
at the National Human
Genome Research Institute
at the NIH and epidemiology
and behavioral medicine back at Howard.
And today, she directs the
Duke Center on Genomics Race,
Identity, and Difference in
the Duke Center for Truth,
Racial, Healing and Transformation.
Her research, scholarship,
and teaching focus on ethical,
social, scientific, and
clinical implications
of human genetics and genomics,
particularly issues at the intersection
of genetics and race.
And she also serves on numerous national
and international advisory
boards and committees
for government agencies,
professional organizations,
research initiatives,
not for profit entities and corporations.
And as I've learned has a
very busy travel schedule.
So we're very grateful to her
for making time to visit New Haven.
Our moderator today is
Professor Brandon Ogbunu
who teaches in the Department
of Ecology and Evolutionary Biology here
and is also a member
of the Terry Committee.
And he uses experimental
evolution, mathematical modeling,
and computational biology
to better understand
the underlying causes and consequences
of disease across scales,
and also writes frequently
for nonacademic audiences
on a wide range of topics
and with great wit,
and you can find his articles in venues
like Wired, Medium and
Scientific American.
And I also want to
acknowledge Professor Ogbunu
and Professor Tom Near
as the co-organizers
of the event today.
Professor Near is
the Chair of Ecology and
Evolutionary Biology.
He's also the Bingham
Oceanographic Curator
of Ichthyology at the Peabody Museum
and Head of College at Saybrook College.
And he mentioned to me that he
was inspired to help organize
this event because he grew up,
"Eyes wide open in the United States."
And is eager to include these topics
in the biology curriculum
here at Yale, in particular,
in the sequence of courses
that every pre-med student
and biology major takes in Yale College.
So thank you to my co-organizers
and please join me in
welcoming Professor Royal.
(audience applauding)
- Well, thank you.
And thank you, Brandon and Tom,
and all those who invited me here.
I am delighted to be here.
I was telling them that
it's been a long time
since I've been to Yale.
My sister did her postgraduate
work here in the 90s,
and that probably was the
last time I was at Yale.
So it's great to be back.
The ethics of knowledge making.
I was fascinated by that.
And I can't think of too many other topics
where making knowledge
requires us to think
about the ethical issues related
to the making of that knowledge
as race and racism.
And today I'm gonna talk about historical,
we're gonna do a little bit of history
and I have a bunch of history
of science people in here.
I'm not gonna get into the details,
but just do a cursory overview of some
of the key milestones
in the creation of this idea of race
and the racism that goes along with that.
I'm gonna present some
data from some of my work
on how people think about race.
And I have developed
an interest in looking at
different groups, different,
I don't wanna call 'em stakeholder groups,
different interest groups and
how they think about this.
So I've looked at
geneticists, anthropologists,
general population, and clinicians,
and I'm gonna present some of those data
in terms of how they think
about this concept of race
and applied in their work.
And then I'm gonna talk a little bit
about race based medicine
and some of the challenges with that.
And I'm gonna,
I have some case studies
after talking about
the perspectives of some of these groups,
I'm gonna do some case studies.
I'm gonna talk a bit
about sickle cell disease,
which is one of my areas of work.
And then talk a bit about
race based medicine and
some of the issues that are arising now
in terms of how we do medicine,
how we practice medicine,
utilizing concepts of
race and the questions
about where do we go
from here and how do we,
and whether we not use race anymore.
And then I'm gonna wrap up.
That sounds like two
days of talks (laughs)
that I'm gonna wrap up
by talking a little bit
about how I teach about race and racism
and giving an example of a course
that I call my signature
course that I teach at Duke.
That is a course that
the students energize me,
I hope as much as I inspire them.
So that's the frame for
what we're gonna do today.
So when I think of history,
one of the first people that come
to my mind is John Hope Franklin,
who was a professor at Duke.
He also was a professor at Howard,
which is where I got all my degrees
so we have a lot in common.
He also loves orchids
and I'm an orchids console here as well.
So we have quite a bit in common.
But in one of his most widely read books
From Slavery to Freedom,
he made this statement,
"If the house is to be set in order,
we cannot begin with the present,
we must begin with the past."
And so we're gonna do a little bit of past
because the past is what informs
how we deal with the
present and the future.
So I'm gonna go through a few slides
with, again, not an
exhaustive history of race
and the idea of race,
but just some points
that I think are relevant
to what we gonna be talking about.
So in terms of people thinking about,
I guess I could take my mask off, can I?
That'll be better for
you and for me. (laughs)
So in thinking about race
and the creation of the idea,
of course, as we know, race
and racism has everything
to do with people and how
people see each other.
So once people,
and in this case, European,
mostly explorers back in the
15th Century and probably
before started engaging with
people who looked differently
from them, those ideas
of who are these people?
Why are they different?
How are they different?
Started to percolate.
So we have European Explorers.
We have the start of the
Transatlantic Slave Trade,
the movement of people
across the Atlantic,
from different parts of Africa going
to other parts of the world.
And so those ideas
started to percolate, but
in the 18th Century, we had scientists
also doing their thing in their labs and
wherever they did them in their homes,
wherever these ideas came from.
we had Carolus Linnaeus, Mr. Taxonomy,
who started grouping
humans based on geography
and came up with his
four part grouping there.
And then later on, we
have Blumenbach who many,
not all credit or discredit
with the creation of this idea
of race in terms of the
hierarchies that we have.
And so we have Blumenbach,
his dissertation work,
and then later publications
creating these categories and
becoming one of the first,
and there were other people
doing this around that time,
but he's is one of the key
ones in terms of creating
this hierarchy based on what he viewed
as the most beautiful people
from the caucuses mountains
and putting one of the people
who came up with the word Caucasian,
and then putting everybody else below.
And then we have Thomas Jefferson,
Third President of the US
being one of the first
prominent US leaders
to actually put forward this idea
that people who we call black people,
people of African descent
are less than or inferior
to people who we call in the US
at least who we call whites.
So one of the first people
to start using these...
You see, he talks about species
and taking from the scientists work
and bringing it into how society starts
to think about people and difference.
Then we have the first census in 1790,
and you may not be able to read this.
I don't expect you to read all of it,
but what I want you to
see this is created by,
developed by the census in 2012,
showing how categories,
census categories have changed
since the first census in 1790,
where race was used in the census.
And you see the categories there,
and this shows how these
categories have changed over time,
over time, they have changed.
The one category in the census that has
not changed, doesn't anybody know?
Which category has not really changed
over all these years from 1790 to,
I cut it off 'cause it was
too big so you stopped there.
But if you go to that website,
it's an interactive resource.
You can click on these and it
gives you all the information,
click on any of these and
you get more information,
click on the dates, you
get more inter information
about all of those identities.
Doesn't anybody know?
Anybody can tell me. Somebody here?
White has not changed.
Who belongs to that
group has changed, right?
Who can be included and
excluded has changed over time,
but the category itself has not.
All these other categories have changed.
And you see where Chinese came in,
mostly from immigration,
we get a lot of information just
from this graphic.
And so the census, and I show the census
and I mentioned the census
because the census is key
to how we think about race.
And when we look at the US census today,
the category is that we use in the census
very much mirror Blumenbach's
taxonomies very much.
Now, we're saying we need to move away.
We don't use Caucasian in the census
anymore in the US, but we did,
it was there, it's not there anymore.
Different countries as we
know have different census.
And most of what I talk about today,
'cause we don't have time to
get into the global aspects
of race which could take us
in some other directions.
But over time,
these have changed.
But the census becomes important
because we use it in research.
We use those categories in research,
we use it in clinical, we
use them in clinical care
and the questions about
why and how and whether
we ought to use them are
some of the big questions.
And then we have Darwin,
Father of Evolution
and his writings
on the Origin of Species
and then Descent of Man.
And in Descent of Man,
he actually became one
of the first people,
and there are lots of things
we could say about Darwin
and we are not gonna talk
a lot about Darwin today,
but one of the first prominent scientists
to question this notion of
the existence of human races.
Eugenics have cause
of Darwin,
Galton actually coined the term
and brought that home movement in
and Charles Davenport
who started the Eugenics
Record Office here in the US
in 1910
at Cold Springs Harbor.
So eugenics became a thing and people
will argue that we still
have eugenics today.
Not so much argue that we still have it
in all kinds of forms
so eugenics as a movement.
And in the early 19s,
early 20th Century to
the mid 20th Century,
there was a series of
debates among anthropologists
and biologists, Montague
and race and Livingston,
about just very similar to
those debates we're having
right now about race and the
existence of race and ethnicity
and what they are and what they're not,
and what biology says about them.
And then we have Richard Lewontin
from Harvard who in the
1970s did studies looking
at blood group antigens
and looking at populations
across the world.
And there are all kinds
of things we could say
about those studies he did in the 70s,
but his studies were
some of the first ones
to tell us a bit about genetic variation,
biological variation
among populations and told us that most
of the genetic variation we
see is within populations
about 85% or so of genetic variation
can be found within populations
and very little variation
between populations.
And then the human genome
project that confirmed
some of Lewontin's work
and some of the previous
work that as humans,
as a human species, we are more alike
than we're different,
99.9% the same we say as humans.
And around the time of
the Human Genome Project
just before it ended and after,
we had other scientists
that were using different
kinds of methods, Alan
Templeton in the 90s
and early 2000s used right statistic,
which is a methodology of
looking at genetic variation,
and geneticist population,
genetics has still used right statistic
and using that statistic as a
measure of genetic variation,
looking at variation within population,
within individual groups
and then as a measure of,
and looking at their in
relation to the globe,
the broader population
and looking at humans in relation
to other organisms
and concluding that humans
have very little variation
within the group, genetic variation.
So again, right statistic less than 0.25,
when you look across the human genome,
we're saying probably
about 0.1, five, six,
in terms of this particular statistic,
very low variation within the population.
And the statistic used
generally says, if variation is,
if the right statistic is below 0.25,
then we can say humans
don't have biological race.
And when I say biological race,
and I know that we have some
evolutionary people in here,
and there are all kinds
of ideas and theories about
how we think about race,
and for some evolutionary biologists,
race is synonymous with subspecies,
which is a level of divergence
below the level of the species.
And when we look at humans,
we don't see that level of
divergence in terms of variation.
And so using a biological measure,
we can say humans don't
have biological race.
But what people often say is that
biological race doesn't exist.
And many in evolutionary
biology would say, it does,
it just doesn't exist in humans.
Many will say for some organisms,
and if you look here,
you'll say, and again,
we could debate this, but many
will say for some organisms,
you could say they have
biological race because of the
amount of variation
within those populations,
but for humans, we don't.
And there are other studies
that show, talk about
that give us information about the origins
of humans and this one
by John Novembre and Colleagues
that that confirmed studies
that we had already seen
about the common origin,
the African origin of humans,
again, confirming that we are one species,
one origin, same people.
We don't have biological
variation to that rises
to the level of subspecies
or the level of race.
So we say, there's no
biological race in humans.
And these are four criteria
and there may be more,
some may add others to it,
but these are four criteria
that we often use in genetics
and some other sciences
to say that humans don't
have biological race.
We look at geographic variation.
And when we look at populations globally,
there's no place that we can
say one population starts
and the other one end.
Variation is overlapping, it's continuous,
and they're not these discrete boundaries.
Gene frequency, Lewontin showed us
and other studies have shown
us more genetic variation
within groups than between.
Morphology, which is one of
the big markers that we use
to define race.
And I'll talk about
social race in a minute,
but we used to define race.
When we look at morphology,
we see non concordance,
what people call kinky
hair doesn't necessarily go
with dark skin
or with a broad nose or all these features
that we tie to races.
They're not obligatory really linked
to each other or to disease.
We can see people with blonde hair,
blue eyes in Sierra Leone or
in the Solomon Islands, in
other places from Europe,
different from Europe.
And then lineage, as I said before,
no subspecies,
no separate lineages within humans,
it's one lineage, one species.
So using these criteria, we say,
humans don't have biological race.
Some people will say, race does not exist.
Race does not exist in humans,
but that's not exactly true.
We don't have biological race based
on these data that I just present,
but social race exists
'cause we've created it.
It exists and it has real
implications on people's lives.
The problem is that we
conflate those two things
which is the reason for the seminar today.
It's like, what is race?
Is it biological? Is it social?
How do we distinguish those two things?
And how do we resolve the
complications that come
from linking those two things.
So saying biological race
exists, but not in humans.
Socially defined or socially
constructed race is real,
we've created it and it has
impacts on people's lives,
including biological
impacts and influences.
So distinguishing those
two things is critical
as we think about race.
what does biology say about race?
What do humans have to say about
what we've created that we call race?
So as I said before, have
become as more I study race,
it's more, I have become interested
in getting real empirical
data about what people think
and people who will use this information,
people who are using
and developing studies.
And so some colleagues and I, colleagues
at University of Washington
like (indistinct)
and others did a study a few years ago,
looking at anthropologists
and geneticists,
anthropology professionals
and genetics professionals.
And we surveyed large numbers.
And you see here where we started,
who was invited and then
we got for geneticists,
we have 1,500, anthropologists,
we invited for 4,000,
we ended up with 300, 3,000 and something
and then written comments.
So I'm gonna just show you
some of the data that we got
and then some of the quantitative
as well as qualitative.
And we've published these studies.
One of them is still in progress in terms
of the quantitative study for geneticists.
But I'm gonna show you
some data that compare
the perspectives between
geneticists and anthropologists.
And I showed you those four
criteria that we use to say,
humans don't have biological race.
But as we know in the
field, and I'm a geneticist,
I know within the field of human genetics,
even though we say there is consensus,
there are differences of opinion
and these data showed us that.
And so these are some of those data.
So what we did, Mike and I,
we picked some statements that
we call common statements.
And these are statements
that people make all the time
and say, they'll say,
geneticists agree on this
or don't agree on this.
And these are some of
these, races don't exist,
race has no biological basis,
race is biological,
meaningless, dah, dah, dah.
As we asked this,
we and the surveys were the same for
both the geneticists
and the anthropologists,
but just changing them
accordingly in terms of
when we asked them about their disciplines
and all of that, that's the only part
that was different in
terms of demographics,
but everything was the same.
What do you notice? Anybody?
What do you notice when
you look at these data?
Huh?
Exact opposite, right? (laughs)
I will say that most
of the anthropologists
were cultural anthropologists,
which might not surprise us.
The geneticists were
mostly clinical geneticists
and genetic counselors,
but we had molecular geneticists,
population geneticists as well.
So that might have something
to do what we are seeing,
but what we see here is
exact opposite responses.
I'm just gonna show some
of the quantitative data,
qualitative data, I may
not be able to show,
I have a bunch of quotes.
This came from a geneticist,
"Geneticists who say that race
doesn't exist are in denial.
Obviously they have never
looked at the results
of an AIMS, ancestry informative markers,
that's what that is, Panel
on 1,000 African Americans
and 1,000 European Caucasians.
And clearly the outmoded
racial identifiers work
more often than it fails.
That's the science, regardless
of anyone's opinion."
That's a geneticist.
We asked the question
and this is something
I've long been interested in,
and I've actually written on this
that we should replace race.
I've rethought that I
wrote that paper in 2006.
I have some thoughts about changing that.
I still think we need to get rid of it,
but I think some things
I wrote in that paper,
I might have said differently.
But the question of whether
we need to do away with race
and replace it with something else.
So these were some of
the questions we asked.
And in general, you see
that there's some agreement
that we need to come up with
something else apart from race.
Well, as work has moved
forward over the years,
there are those who have
been asking and wondering
whether we are asking the right questions.
We're asking use race, don't use race
as if those are the only two options.
There may be questions
that we haven't asked.
When should we use race?
Why? How?
Those are the probably
some of the questions
that we need to ask
instead of dichotomizing
it the way we have, but
I'm not quite there yet,
but I'm getting there.
"Race is a four letter word
that needs to be retired
and removed from the
dictionary and common use.
As an anthropologist and human geneticist,
I have watched as modern
methods of measuring variation
in humans have made the word
a 19th Century anachronism
with no scientific value."
I'm gonna jump over to some of these.
The question of how we take
this information to healthcare.
These based on how we think about race,
the knowledge, the information we know
that biological race does not exist,
but we see these health differences,
how do we reconcile those things?
And then there was
somebody who's just like,
forget this human business. (laughs)
I just don't have to deal with this,
forgetting that they're part of society
and they gotta deal with it too.
So in thinking about looking
at the general population,
So we did a surveys
colleagues at UNC Chapel Hill
and myself and colleagues
at Duke did a survey,
a national survey of the US population.
We had about 1700 people,
a representative sample of
the US population on race.
And this was one question
one of my undergrads is working on this,
looking at people's perceptions
of the differences between
race, ethnicity, and ancestry.
This is a qualitative question,
open-ended question and so we coded,
and these are the responses
we got in terms of the
definitions of those words.
"Cause as you know, these
terms are used interchangeably
and we still are so confused
about how we distinguish them,
but that's not our conversation today.
We're gonna focus on race,
But anybody can tell me quickly,
what is one thing you notice
on that bar graph?
One thing that strikes you on that.
- [Participant] Physical
geographical (indistinct)
- [Royal] They are.
(indistinct)
That's right, yes.
That is definitely one of the things
that is striking in this on this.
Anybody else? Anything else?
- [Participant 2] (indistinct)
Very positive (indistinct)
(audience laughing)
- [Royal] And what did most
of them say they don't know?
Ethnicity, right? Which
we found interesting.
Most people did not know
how to define ethnicity.
They could tell you something about race,
whether it was correct or not,
they could give you a definition for race.
And when we asked them about their race,
they could tell us something.
When we asked people about
their ethnicity, I don't know,
they give you their race.
Mostly Hispanic people would say,
they use race and ethnicity,
many of the Hispanics in
the study, the same thing,
but most people, and even
we did that in a pilot
and it's the same thing.
Most people have no
clue what ethnicity is,
whether how to define it or
what their ethnicity might be.
And that's something we're
following up on more.
We also see that for genetic
and we could look at genetic
and physical as similar,
but for genetic, of course,
race more likely,
most people were more likely
to link race and genetics.
When we ask the question
about the existence
of biological human races,
this is what we saw.
So we have gender left,
right black, white.
And what we see and the
line going across is a mean
for all the other groups,
blacks and white were our largest groups,
the other groups were small
so we did them in terms
of what they're showing us
on these graphs.
And we see that education,
people with with less education
were more likely to think
that whether they were men identified
as men or women were more likely
to think that biological races exist.
We found that people identified
as white were more likely
to think that biological races exist.
We have a scale that we are
in the process of validating.
And we'd used this scale in this.
And on that scale, looking
at race and genetics,
asking people various things
about the relationship
between race and genetics,
and this is how they scored.
And people who were black were
more likely to score higher
on that scale than people
identified as white.
Younger people were more
likely to score higher,
which may not necessarily
be very surprising.
And yeah, just some of the findings there.
When we ask people for their comments,
there are people who
are thinking race needs
to go, so much baggage,
people who didn't even know what to say
because there is so much
that they could think of.
Many people said they just never
even thought about these differences
and wanted to know more.
And then just like our
other is complicated,
it's complicated and we
know it's complicated.
And it's this complexity that has led me
to do some of the work I do.
I've become very interested in complexity.
And this is
a model that colleagues and I developed
and published in 2009.
This is when I was at Howard
and this was part of an NIH grant we had.
And what we did
in this model is utilize
data mainly most of the data
were data related to African Americans
and looking at variables
that influence health
and interactions, and came
up with this model looking
at various domains in terms of,
we looked at genetics, we looked at
where people are, their identities,
their social and environmental exposures,
their psychological...
My cursor all over the place.
But anyway, we looked at a range
of variables here and their
influences on outcomes,
not just status of
health, but drug response,
health perception, a range
of responses informed by data
in that literature.
And in that paper in 2009,
we put out the idea,
which is an idea I've had for a long time
about sickle cell disease and looking
at sickle cell disease as a model
to help us understand complexity,
gene environment interactions.
Now, sickle cell disease,
I'm gonna just do a little bit for those
who may not know about
sickle cell disease.
First, the first known
publication, at least in the US,
when I talked to my African
colleagues, they're like,
we've been talking about
this thing for a long time,
we just didn't know what to call it.
we didn't have a journal to publish it in.
And so we say 1910 was the
First published Case in the US
on sickle cell disease published
by James Herrick who
identified the first person,
first person identified
Walter Clement Noel in the US
in Chicago.
He was a Grenada dental student in Chicago
at University of Chicago
and became ill
and they found these elongated cells
and they were published.
And over time, we've learned a lot
about sickle cell disease.
in 1949, Linus Pauling and others told us
about the molecular basis
of sickle cell disease
that is a point mutation
in the hemoglobin gene.
And you see here, this scheme shows
what we call normal hemoglobin.
We're careful about how
we use these words normal,
but we're just gonna
use it today. (chuckles)
And then sickle, and it's one change,
one base sphere change in the genetic code
from a T to an A that gives
us a different amino acid
from glutamic acid to valine
and the production of
this different amino acid
gives us hemoglobin S,
which is a sickle hemoglobin.
Normal hemoglobin, that one on the left,
the red cells are pliable and soft,
and they can slide through the vesicles,
the small veins and capillaries.
The sickle cells, however, become rigid
because they've lost oxygen, the result of
of the valine produces a
decrease in amount of oxygen,
cells become sticky, they clump together
and going through cells, vesicles,
capillaries, and veins
cause a lot of pain.
They cause blockage, what
we call vasal occlusion,
which is part of the
hallmark of the disease.
We also learned in the 1950s
from AC Allison about the link
between sickle hemoglobin and malaria.
And what you see here on
the left is historically
where malaria was and on
the right sickle cell trait,
sickle cell trait.
We also learned, I didn't say before,
the inheritance of sickle cell disease
is an autosomal recessive disorder.
So both parents have to have a trait
and when they have a
child with every child
that those parents have,
if each of them has a
trait, with every child,
there's a 25% chance
that they could have a
child with the disease.
And it's the trait that
is linked to malaria.
And then when people have
come together with a trait,
then they could have a
child with a disease.
So the presence of sickle cell trait.
Sickle cell trait arose as
part of natural selection
to protect people from
death, from malaria.
So classic case of natural selection.
And here we see where malaria is today,
still mostly in Africa and
some parts of South America.
But for most part of the
world, it does not exist.
Sickle cell disease is also probably,
probably the most racialized disease.
There are other diseases
that are racialized,
but sickle cell disease has been.
And this perception
that sickle cell disease
is a black disease
has been part of the problem that people
with the disease have in
terms of their treatment.
And part of my interest,
I worked on sickle cell
disease in my graduate work
and as a genetic counselor
at a Sickle Cell Center
and got interested in very,
more interested in diseases.
I saw families
with children with sickle cell disease
and the children I had,
I remember one family with
five children affected
with sickle cell disease.
And each one of them was different
in terms of their outcomes.
One child was pretty much symptom free.
You wouldn't even know that
they had sickle cell disease
and then another one in
the hospital all the time
and then another one died early.
And that variability struck me
and I thought there's gotta be...
And in grad school, I learned
about the genetic factors
that influenced that
but I was also interested in
what are the other things?
So the racialization of sickle
cell disease is a big part
of the story of the disease.
We can't talk about it
without the racialization.
So sickle cell disease affects
just about every organ.
Every organ system is
affected and again is affected
in some people, some people
don't have a lot of symptoms,
but most people will
have some from your eye,
all the way to your toes can
be affected as you see there.
It's also global.
There are about 20 million people globally
with sickle cell disease
most of them are in three countries
in the Congo, Republic of the
Congo, Nigeria, and India.
Most of them are in Africa.
And we see the numbers there
and mostly countries below
the Maghreb Countries
in Africa.
And so we see sickle cell
disease as a global disease.
In the US, about 100,000
people with the disease.
We see a lot of inequities
in sickle cell disease.
And many people don't
think about the inequities
and the disparities in sickle cell disease
'cause many people say,
well, we know it's...
Well, some people think
of it as a black disease.
Some people say, we know
it's not a black disease,
but mostly black people
have it, which is true.
Mostly people who identify as
African, at least in the US,
but the disease is also
very common in Greece.
There are some parts of Greece
that have more sickle cell disease
than some parts of Africa, South Africa,
for example, doesn't really
have sickle cell disease.
Most of the people there are people
who come from other
parts of the continent.
And so when we think about
sickle cell disease, it's global,
Turkey, Middle East, India,
very, very much global.
But in general, both here in the US
and globally has received
little attention compared
to other diseases in terms of funding
and other things.
And this is produced
by the CDC Foundation,
showing some of the disparities
in terms of life expectancy,
returning to the hospital,
I talked about pain,
the hallmark of the disease,
more likely even when you
compare sickle cell disease with
other diseases that have
pain associated with them,
there's studies, there was
a study done by colleagues
at Hopkins looking at patients
with long bone fracture.
And what happens very often is that people
with sickle cell disease,
because they suffer from such severe pain,
have to take narcotics for the most part
to deal with the pain
and they're always in
the ER for the most part.
And very often they,
as we go down here,
I'm not gonna get to go
through all of these.
But patients are often
seen as drug seeking
and in the US, as we said,
most of the patients are patients
who identify as African American.
There are many patients who identify
as Hispanic too with sickle cell disease.
But that is one key component
of sickle cell disease
experience that people have.
And I'm interested in knowing
do people across the world in
other countries have that experience
as I think about race
and how it plays out.
And then we also know that the number
of physicians who are
willing to see people
with sickle cell disease
is also a small number.
Some people just don't
wanna deal with them.
Now in thinking about factors
that influence sickle cell disease,
we've long known that
there are genetic factors.
It's a classic Mendelian
single gene disorder.
You can't get it unless you
inherit those those variants
from both of your parents.
And so there are these genetic factors,
the hemoglobin genotype,
whether you're SS there're about,
there're over 1,000 hemoglobin variants,
S is the most severe
and the one we talk about here,
but there's C as well and S
with another abnormal hemoglobin
will result in sickle cell disease.
But the genotype, the haplotype
and all these are genetic factors.
But less well known
are non-genetic factors
that influence sickle cell disease.
And these are some of them, climate,
all aspects of climate
and I'm gonna try to wrap up soon (laughs)
that influenced sickle cell disease,
but all of these,
and there are studies that have looked
at these factors.
And this is a paper
published by Piel and others
from the UK where
they created this image of
some of the genetic modifiers,
the non-genetic modifiers.
But what I found interesting
in their paper is
that they never brought 'em together.
So we're looking at the
genetic modifiers up here.
We're looking at the
environmental modifiers down here.
I have long been interested in bringing
all of those things together.
And this is an image from a paper
that we published last year
that has seven domains.
And as you notice, there are
no no boundaries between those,
because what we know is that all
of these things are operating together
at the same time and
understanding that complexity,
it's challenging, but it's a must
if we really wanna understand
the mechanisms of the disease.
And so the paper we published put forward
this idea of looking
at sickle cell disease,
and we used pain as an example.
All of what you see there is
informed by the literature.
The arrows are factors
that exacerbate pain,
the circles are factors
that have been shown
to ameliorate pain.
So as we think about health and disease
and race and racism, thinking about fact,
not just factors that cause
disease or make disease worse,
but also factors that can
help have a positive impact on
on our health and outcomes,
both are equally important.
And this was a timeline we created looking
at various factors as they go up and down,
the pain is going up, going
down as different factors,
the factors from these domains
and how people's health is increasing
as their pain decreases.
And so this work in terms of
looking at the complexity,
and I'm gonna move on 'cause I know I've
gotta wrap up soon
is something that we we've done in,
we just did a preliminary study looking
at people with sickle cell disease
in Jamaica, Cameroon, and South Africa.
And well, we did South Africa too,
but this publication
was focused on Jamaica,
Cameroon and the US.
And for various reasons,
we couldn't do the comparisons.
We're looking at existing data.
We wanted to look at gene
environment interactions,
but for all kinds of reasons,
some sites didn't have
genetic information,
some didn't have environmental,
so we just picked one that had
the most robust set of data,
and that was Jamaica.
And what we found, we found associations
in terms of age, in terms
of atmospheric temperature,
rainfall, zinc,
lower zinc was a risk factor
for pain and greater poverty.
So these were some factors that we found
that influenced severity of
pain or increased severe pain.
We're surprised not to find any
differences across genotypes
because the genotypes
are known to be factors
that influence severity.
So there might be some things
that we need to look at there.
I'm gonna move very quickly into talking
about race based medicine.
And what you saw there
was just the assumptions
that underlie race based medicine.
And race based medicine, when
I say race based medicine,
I'm thinking about
practicing medicine based
on these racial categories,
how we treat people,
the drugs that we give them,
the treatments that we give them
and the things that we
think will work best
for them in terms of their health.
And the assumptions are that races exist.
And that races, biological races exist,
that they differ in
their genetic components
and that these differences influence
those health outcomes.
So I'm gonna talk very
quickly about BiDil,
which is a drug, the first drug approved
by the FDA to treat a
specific racial group.
Has everybody in here heard about BiDil?
Some people have.
Anybody never, never heard about BiDil?
Oh, we have some people who
never heard about BiDil?
We're gonna take a couple
of minutes, just a couple,
'cause I don't wanna take away from you.
I can't talk about BiDil
in a couple minutes,
but I'm gonna try to do it.
So BiDil is a combination
of two generic drugs,
Isosorbide dinitrate and
Hydralazine hydrochloride.
These are two generic
drugs that have been used
by cardiologists over the years,
since the 1970s or before
to treat heart failure.
And they've used these
two generic drugs in
different combinations
to treat people with heart failure.
And when I say treat people, black,
white, yellow, green, blue people,
everybody, they use them
and they'd use did in
different combinations
to treat different people.
In the 1970s, a researcher
at Minnesota is a clinician,
J Kahn started using putting
these two drugs together
in particular combinations.
And over time he sold the rights
to a company called NitroMed,
got a patent on it and is a long story,
they got three patents on it.
They applied to the FDA in
the 80s to get it approved
to treat heart failure in blacks
because some study that
they had done had shown
that it works better in black
people and other people.
And they thought, okay, we need to get
the FDA to approve this for
us to treat black people.
Applied to the FDA, '96,
the FDA turned them down
and said, "No, you need to go do a study
that will show that it works better
for black people than other people."
So they designed the
study called the A-HeFT,
African American Heart Failure Trial.
And the trial started in 2001.
And in 2003, they discontinued the trial.
There was a placebo trial
so there were half of the people
at 1,050 people were in this study,
half of them got placebo
and standard treatment
and the standard treatment
was either ACE inhibitors
or diuretics.
So they got a placebo and standard
and the other half got standard and BiDil.
And so in 2003, they ended the trial
because the group that was getting BiDil,
they know when they compared the two,
the group that was getting BiDil,
had a reduction of death
from heart failure,
43%, big percentage.
So they had to end it
because it would've been
unethical to continue.
So the end of the trial, 2003.
And at that time, sought
to get another patent,
they did get another patent.
They have had three patents,
that the whole patent
story is a whole big story.
Jonathan Kahn, who's
probably written the most
on this has actually
written a book on BiDil.
So you can look him up Jonathan Khan
if you wanna learn more about that.
But the interesting thing about BiDil,
one of the interesting
things about BiDil is that,
as I said before, is the first drug ever
to be approved by the FDA for
a particular racial group.
The Company, NitroMed once in 2005,
it was approved by the FDA.
in 2008, the company went out of business
and a couple other companies bought it.
It's now owned by a company
called Arbor Pharmaceuticals,
which is where this came
from on their website.
So they're still marketing the drug.
There are a couple of people are...
We don't have a ton of data.
My team, and I have done
some empirical studies on
physicians use of BiDil.
This is a study we did with cardiologists,
but there are really not many studies
on BiDil and trying to understand
why it failed so early.
The NAACP, the Congressional Black Caucus,
the Association of Black Cardiologists
all supported this at the time.
Now, I talked to many of them
and many of them didn't know
that this was what the company was going
for to get it approved to
treat a specific racial group.
I testified at the hearing for this,
for the approval, my
colleagues and I at Howard,
I was at Howard at the time.
We were black folks
over on the side saying,
"Do not approve this drug
just for black people."
And then we have the
Congressional Black Caucus saying,
"We've been discriminated against,
give us our drug, it's our time.
We gotta address health disparities."
Very, very interesting hearing.
The FDA ended up approving it.
This was a study that we had done.
There's so much I could see about this,
but we don't have time. (laughs)
These are some findings from a study
we did some colleagues
and I did into 2019.
We just published another
paper with some findings
that were similar.
But what we found is
that some cardiologists
are still using BiDil,
but for most of them,
they give it to anybody
for whom it will work.
Is approved just for
self-identified blacks
that's what the indication says.
And so people are approving it off label
are prescribing it off
label to other people
for whom it works as we see there,
not only given to black patients.
And for many of them,
the primary criterion was not race
in terms of why they prescribed it.
This was the indication
what else was going on
with that person in terms of their health.
And then there are some that believe
that it was appropriate to do that,
for the FDA to do that
and others said that.
Bottom line is lots of
questions among physicians,
even about BiDil and whether
they should have been done,
but it's been done still the only case
for which this has been
done, lots of issues there.
And we may talk about some of them later
about why the FDA saw it fit to do this
for this drug and not for other drugs.
For other studies where there were
no black people over years.
And so their thing was that this study was
just done with black people
and so it can only be
approved for black people.
Well, studies long time ago
didn't include any black people
and we get all those drugs
that all of us are using.
And so why is it different?
So lots and lots of issues there.
I'm gonna, and this was
from that same study
that our doctor said to us that
my white patients would walk
in and say, "Give me that
black drug, is working for me."
They just wanna know
what's working for them.
So we put these labels on
these things and people,
many people don't really care.
So in terms of race based medicine,
the paper that colleagues and I wrote
about precision medicine, there's this
all this talk about precision medicine.
And we wrote this paper,
it wasn't a question.
And we talked in that paper, we talked,
you used some examples,
but also talked about what it would take
for us to move beyond race and
whether we can even do that.
Then some colleagues,
the same year wrote a piece on taking race
out of human genetics studies.
And that's been a big conversation about
whether genetic and genomic studies
should be even using the concept of race.
And then we had this
study that was published
a little later last year
where some geneticists
and others are saying,
"Hold up a minute, not so
quick with getting rid of race.
There may be some utility to this."
And these are geneticists
and they gave some studies about how race,
even more than genetic
ancestry in some cases
was predictive of health outcomes.
So there continues to be
the debate about this,
and whether we use this
in genetic studies.
I co-chair a National Academies
Committee that is looking
at this very issues about
use of race and other
such descriptors in genetic studies.
I'm gonna move on quickly because
I wanna do the Q&A and we are past time.
This slide and the next
couple slides are really
just about where we are
in the conversations.
So there's been a lot of
conversations recently in this
since 2020 in the death
of George Floyd and all,
a lot of things that have been happening
about how we use race in
medicine and about algorithms.
You've heard about the eGFR
and how these algorithms
are used to describe
to determine who gets what treatments.
And that these algorithms are based
on ideas about race.
So eGFR, the estimated
glomerular filtration rate
and this algorithm that has been used
to give different
treatments to black patients
from white patients,
because of the prolonged
standing perception
that black patients have more muscle mass
than white patients
and so they excrete more creatinine.
So you look at a level of
creatinine and you have
to adjust your algorithm
because black people
have more muscle mass.
So these ideas longstanding, but
they influence what we do today.
So wrapping up, I really am
wrapping up now. (chuckles)
Where do we go from here?
I presented a lot of
issues, a lot of problems.
And I have here, what I call
the biomedical ecosystem
is all of the entities,
and these may not be all,
but some of the key ones
that have to be involved
in any efforts to change
what I've been talking
about this whole time
to change how we use race in society,
in health research, in clinical practice,
it takes more than just the geneticists
or the social scientists,
bringing us back to our
conversation about how we think
about knowledge and making knowledge and
how we make ethical knowledge.
It has to be informed by multiple voices
for us to think through all of the issues.
And one of the areas that I am gonna talk
about just really quickly
is the area of training.
There's a course that I teach
at Duke called Race Genomics in Society,
where I bring all of
these things together,
bringing genetics and
I do a Pri on genetics
and talk about how genetics is influences
and how people think about
athletics and intelligence
and skin color and help them understand
how these things come to be
and what genetics says or not
and how society says about these things.
And then talking about help.
And this fall, I'm always
doing different things
with this class.
And this fall, last fall,
I had the experience of a lifetime
where I asked the students and I've kept
that course at 100 students.
So this semester, this fall,
we had 96 students who 98
started in 96 at the class.
And one of their assignments
was to create a piece of
art at the end of the class
for throughout the class,
but a piece of art that represented
what they took away
and it had to be a piece of
art that brought together
the genetics and the social
and all of the factors.
And they could focus on
one module, say skin color,
or they could do a
combination, ancestry testing,
skin color, intelligence, whatever.
And the students created, they
had an eight and a half 11,
I worked with people in my arts department
and it was it's four discussion sections
and they created these art
and these are the four panels.
And I can't tell,
and each of them had to
write a 150 word statement
that described their piece.
It is now on display in
our Rubinstein Art Center,
which is our big center
Art Center at Duke.
And I can't tell you what it means for me
to see what they wrote,
not because it says anything about me,
but because it tells me about the future,
it gives me hope for the future
and how these students took
this information in and how
it informs how they think
about race and racism
and what they will do
in the future.
So I could talk forever about that.
I sat and I read all of
these and I'm thinking,
did they really get this from this?
Fascinating, fascinating.
And then some of them
would say, "I'm no artist."
When you see what they created,
and I said, we are all
artists, it was just great.
I'm gonna end with a slide
by a colleague of mine,
building on how we teach,
how we teach about race and genetics
because for me, how we
communicate the information,
and I say we, I'm talking about faculty
in the academy and others who teach
and how we help people
understand social race
and biological race,
and the difference between the two
and what happens when we conflate the two,
and teaching people so they understand.
And so teaching about this has
been one of my life mission
and a colleague of mine,
Brian Donovan, who works
in Colorado at the Biological
Sciences Curriculum Study,
he's a research scientist there has been,
he works, they work
primarily with K through 12.
And when I finish my Race
Genomics and Society Class,
we always do a so what
at the end of the class,
and invariably students say
this information needs
to be taught earlier,
I didn't learn this until I got here.
And Brian and his team are,
they have been doing studies
and have done studies that
show that how we teach.
And I talked about Mendelian
disorders and how we teach
about Mendelian disorders and
how we teach about the
presence and absence of genes
and how that leads to an outcome
and needing to teach about complexity.
How we teach students at
all levels influences.
And they've done randomized
trials that show that students
who learn about complexity
have different ideas
about the relationships between people,
about what people are capable of
and what genetic differences
mean or don't mean.
And he and I collaborating on some,
getting ready to
collaborate on some things.
So thinking of the ethics
of knowledge making
toward a more humane genetics,
how we think about justice,
how we think about beneficence
and non maleficence
in our teaching about race and genetics
and how those things come together,
leading us to a more humane
genetics and a more humane way
of thinking about the
relationships between these things,
but a more humane way of
living with one another.
I'm gonna stop there. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
All right, Brian, Brandon,
I know I've taken all your time.
- Keep talking as far
as (indistinct) please.
Well, thank you, Professor Royal for that.
I wanted to remind everyone
there's a reception,
We'll go into about 5:30 and
then there is a reception
afterwards right outside,
upstairs, great.
- Some water.
- Yes. You can get as
much water as you can.
(Royal laughs)
- Thank you all for your patience.
I know I went on and on there.
- No.
- All right.
- You take the time.
Well, thank you for that again.
Thank you to the co-organizers.
Thank you, Professors Coen
and Near really, really enjoy.
And obviously thank you, Professor Royal
for solving the problem
of scientific racism
for us over the last hour
really quite thrilling.
I think there's so much in there there's
so many directions to take,
and I think you did a beautiful
job kind of communicating,
not just the topic, but the
topic through your work,
which is, I think was
really quite impressive
how you've been able to address it.
We're gonna start with
something invariably,
you've thought about
with regards to the way
that we address this problem
in contemporary settings.
There's this notion that we are just going
to add more data to the
problem and we will solve it.
We seek more genomes and more
genomes and more genomes,
or perhaps a little more charitably
we get more diverse genomes
for more diverse backgrounds.
And I think when, if we
understand more and more genomes,
we'll kind of solve the problem that way.
And obviously some people who like
when respects even take that approach,
maybe even on thinking about
the problem in a humane way,
as you would articulate it.
I want you to respond to that.
What is your take on that
approach to these problems?
- Okay. So Brian, which mic am I using?
Not the...
This one, right?
- Yeah.
- All right. So I can take this one off.
So to answer your question Brandon and
I think there are some cases...
There's some cases where we
might need more data, (chuckles)
but I wouldn't say we need
more genomic data. (chuckles)
I would say we need more of
the other data. (chuckles)
But we need more genomic
data on some things.
There's some things where,
and when I say some things,
there's some issues where
we don't need anymore data,
we don't need any more data, I think,
and someone argue with me to tell us
that humans don't have biological race.
There are people who
say, well, what if we,
because we often say
humans are young species.
We haven't lived long enough to have,
and people say, well, what if we look
for a million years from now?
Well, we might have some biological areas.
We'll think about that then, right now,
we don't have it.
So in terms of that issue and
how we understand human genetic variation
and human variation, there's
a lot we can understand
about human still
to be understood with
regard to human variation.
But with regard to the issue of race,
I think we have the
information we need right now.
The information that tells us
about our common human origin,
the emotion tells us
about frequency and all,
I think we have enough
to drive home those messages
to people who don't know.
I'm not naive enough to think,
and even in teaching
race genomics in society,
I'm not naive enough to
think that just giving people
that information is gonna take care
of the racism problem.
It's not in and of itself is
gonna take care of the racism,
but it has a role to play.
In our national survey that I showed you,
54% of the US population believe
that there're biological races.
What they understand by biological races,
we didn't get into that, but we will,
but the ideas that surround
that knowledge are important.
And so helping people understand
how we are related to each other
as humans is important,
is still important,
but we have a lot more
work to do in society.
But I think it's gonna
take the geneticists
and the social scientists and
all of us working together
to solve the racism problem.
Collecting more genetic
data and genomic data
can tell us something.
But I think in the end,
we need to collect more
data on the context
within which genes operate
to help us understand this complexity.
And context broadly defined,
not just what we eat,
but the racism that affects
us and influences our health
and help us understand how
those stressors interact
with genetic or other
factors to influence that.
That complexity we don't understand fully
and we are not even close
to understanding it.
So in that case for that,
I think we need more data.
- Fascinating. Thank you for that.
I'm gonna jump around a
little bit if that's okay.
And I think you set the precedent for that
with the way you were
able to elegantly tie
so many parts of this
conversation together.
I think you talked about testifying
for the BiDil in the BiDil
trial kind of decision.
And then you outlined this setting
where you and your colleagues
were articulating these points
about the problems with approving BiDil
and you were in opposition
to these problem,
lawmakers, black lawmakers,
which is the Congression of
Black Caucus who were in favor.
And I think that's a kind of
a good microcosm for the way
these kind of conversations happen where
there is a kind of a social
justice component to the right,
this desire to reify race.
And I want to hear,
and now I wanna now take to your classroom
or invariably, you're able
to teach this effectively.
So I wanna know how you are able to...
I know how you think about it,
'cause you just told us how you think
about it and how you reconcile that,
but how do you able to
communicate to reconcile
that conflict with a lot of people
because it's one that is a barrier,
I think to the the country
understanding in this complexity.
- That's a really good question, Brandon.
I have talked with my
colleagues in the CBC
and at the NAACP about their
myopic way of looking at this.
Of course, they have an agenda that
in some ways different from mine.
And their agenda is to
ensure that the policies
that are put in place in their
minds benefit black people.
When I talk to them,
they understand the
scientific racism argument
that we were trying to make,
that approving this drug just
for black people is sending the message
that many already believe
that black people are
different biologically
and need their own drug.
And so I had them think about
that and for them it's like,
we know that, but
we still need some attention.
- Oh, interesting.
- It's a tough one,
but it requires those
kinds of conversations
to get us across the divides.
When I talk to them about their
roles in the community and
how they need to think about the roles
that they play in reifying these notions
and how the people within
the black community,
"black community", I
use that term in quotes,
look up to them to
protect their interests.
And if their interests, at least
in my view are not informed
are not looking at the big picture.
In their minds, they're
looking at the big picture,
which is social justice.
I'm like, I'm looking at
social justice too, but
we need to figure it out.
The problem, the thing
is that if it's approved
for everyone, black people
will get it too, hopefully.
- You're right.
That's a different problem.
(both laughing)
- They're get it too.
when I think about justice
and social justice,
I think about justice for everybody.
So I think about the Hispanic
people who won't get it
because it's just
approved for black people.
But the other issue is that,
it's not gonna work for every black person
as we saw in the trial.
So what about those people who are black,
who won't respond well to
BiDil, will they get a drug?
So once we go down this path,
it may look like it's serving a purpose
and doing what they think it's gonna do,
but the downsides to not just
people who identify as black
and they're thinking that, okay,
we've given them their drug,
we don't have to try to find another one
that might work for them.
Now, how BiDil has played out in terms
of Arbor Pharmaceuticals is
the company's marketing it,
doctors are still prescribing it,
many black people are not taking it.
I remember in 2005, when
it was approved in 2006,
and I would talk to
people, I was talking to
this man who he was an
uncle of a friend of mine,
and she said, "You need to talk
to my uncle 'cause he won't take BiDil
and he has heart failure."
And I talked to him, I said,
"So why won't you take the drugs?"
He's like, "They developed
that just for us?
Oh no, I'm not gonna take it."
And so we think we're...
And for many people that's probably
why the drug didn't survive.
And also the drug...
There's so many stories.
Many doctors were not
prescribing it for their patients
'cause it was too expensive
for their black patients.
And so there's so many
issues that surround...
It is the first drug that's
done that this has happened to.
So it's the only example we have.
And we haven't done enough
research to really understand all
the facets of what is
happening with BiDil.
And so I think it requires conversation.
I've had conversations with my colleagues
at the CBC and at the NAACP about this.
And over time, they got
upset because the drug,
the price of the drug was so high.
The drug had the highest markup
of any FDA approved, 700%
after it was approved by the FDA, 700%.
And going into this,
people were worried and
were saying to NitroMed,
black people, if you say
this drug for black people
and many people who not able to afford it,
you need to make it
affordable and say, oh,
it's gonna be afforded,
but what it was not.
And so the cost became an an issue.
And so I think
when we think about
how these things play out,
we have to have a broad view
of things
and prioritize, figure out
what's really important.
- Really, really important
'cause every time there's this big,
there's a lot of big public hiccups
around talking about race,
David Reich, talk about,
they always use disease,
these types of things about how,
and I think the way you've been able
to disentangle that is really profound.
I'll ask one last question
and then I'll take
questions from the audience
while we have a few minutes.
just I want to get in,
just go to sickle cell anemia.
I think your work there was
my introduction to your work.
And I think what's beautiful about it
and certainly Professor Near,
I think we teach that as the
canonical Mendelian disease.
And I think we have these
other models of genetics where
everything else is more complex,
but sickle cell is
very, very, very simple.
And I think what your work
has done has blown that open
and articulated that, even that
one, now I think to myself,
wow, is Mendelian disease,
even a proper term for things.
Maybe we needed entire new lexicon
to describe genetics as a whole.
You're succeeding in making all
of our jobs more difficult.
(Royal laughs)
I want you to lean into that
and are there other diseases
you talked about that this is not the
only racialized disease,
as you say, maybe the most,
but kind of lean into that a little bit
and what are some other
kind of thoughts you have
in that direction or other diseases
of that kind or wherever?
- Okay, so good question.
So there's cystic fibrosis,
which is also racialized,
but not in the same way.
But very similarly black people
who have cystic fibrosis,
they're misdiagnosed
just like white people
who have sickle cell
disease are misdiagnosed,
and misdiagnose, as we know,
can be a major problem.
But cystic fibrosis has the
same kind of a complexity,
smoke exposure and da, da, da.
I just published a paper,
well, it was published last
year as well with colleagues
at the National Institute of
Environmental Health Sciences,
looking at sickle cell
disease, cystic fibrosis,
Huntington disease and Parkinson's disease
as four monogenic diseases.
Parkinson's is a little
more variable in terms
of inheritance and looking
at environmental factors.
So the paper was on
environmental influences
on Mendelian diseases.
And for us to start thinking
about Mendelian diseases different.
But your point
about whether Mendelian
is even a way of thinking
about it, guess we could say Mendelian,
but probably not monogenic. (chuckles)
Mendelian still helps
us predict inheritance
and that's really
the pattern, is the
patterns of inheritance.
So the patterns are still there
in terms of how you get it
'cause you can't get it,
these diseases without...
Parkinson's, again is a little different,
but Huntington and sickle cell and CF
you at least right now, as far as we know,
you can only get it by
inheriting those variants.
So how we think about disease and health,
somebody who has two S hemoglobins,
but have no symptoms have no complication,
they're pretty much fine.
Do we say they have sickle cell disease?
Do we say they have a disease?
Well, we may or may not.
And how we think about health and disease,
all of those questions are part of
this issue of complexity and how
we understand complexity.
And the more we look at...
So my thing has always been
all diseases are complex.
All diseases are complex.
They don't just happen.
There are multifactorial, all of them.
Some may be a little
more complex than others
or some, we may be able to predict
their inheritance a little bit
better than other diseases.
We know most breast cancers are sporadic,
but about 10% and prostate
cancer are hereditary.
And so thinking about diseases,
all of them as being complex
and the levels of complexity.
For the Mendelian disorders
or monogenic disorders,
the environmental and social
factors may play a lesser,
not prominent a role in their etiology,
but in the pathophysiology,
they play a major role.
And the more we understand those things,
the better we are able to...
Sickle cell disease is also the thing
at the top of the list for gene editing.
- That's right. That's right.
- And my thing is that even when we think
about who's gonna respond
well to curative therapies,
we need to think about
these other factors.
It's not just plugging in a gene here
and everything is gonna be fine.
- Yeah, no, so much. Great.
Now thank you for that.
We have a few minutes left,
so we'll take a question
or two, if we can,
from the audience, I think, no, no, no.
We have a question.
(indistinct)
- Very good question.
What I would say, and I did
not talk about racism as much,
but I always say there's
no race without racism.
Racism created race.
And racism is what brings this hierarchy
and these ideas about
inferiority and superiority
that drove the creation of race.
So we had these ideas about
who was most beautiful.
We, Blumenbach whomever
about who was most beautiful
and then we created something
to justify those ideas.
So racism and race to me are intertwined.
They're not separate,
they're not separable.
And you're right, I think in many cases,
we talk about race as a
category without talking
about the racism that goes along with it.
And I guess I did some of that
today talking about race and
not so much the racism, but for me,
they're all part of when I
talk about sickle cell disease
and how people are treated in the clinic,
it's because they're racialized
that they're treated in a particular way.
And so they're one and the same to me.
And so
if we say race is a
social construct, it's so,
I hesitate to use, I know,
I rarely say that, race
is a social construct,
as opposed to saying it's
socially constructed.
We made it up.
And using it as a verb
as opposed to a noun,
puts the owners on who
created it on the creation.
So I agree with you
that the racism is what
we need to address.
And the racism is what
to address the racism
in my view will take
us coming together and
getting beyond the separation
that has caused these divides
and helping us, as I say very often,
to see ourselves in the face of the other
and to interact more with each other.
- Any other questions from the audience?
- I talk so much, you have
no questions. Sorry about.
- No, I think there's one.
We see if we can say.
- [Participant 3] Well, there are a couple
of short related questions (indistinct)
- Okay.
So I think that
the conversations about race and racism
and the conversations
about gender and sex,
there are some similarities in
those conversations in terms
of utilizing biology as a
marker of difference now,
but they're different in
terms of how we use that.
I know researchers who
study homosexuality,
for example, and
who identify as gay and
their work is intended
to show that this is a biological trait.
Race is different.
For race, we're trying to show that
what we're calling race and racism
is socially constructed so biology
is not the driver of those differences.
So there are differences
in those conversations
and in the underlying science
of those conversations.
There's also a difference
with race in my view.
I don't apologize for this.
I think there's something
different about race from gender,
from sexuality and any of
those other identities.
I know about intersectionality as well,
but if we do not focus,
if we focus on race and
we can address race,
then in my view, we can
address everything else.
If we don't single race
out and address it,
or at least try to address it,
it constantly gets subsumed
on all these other things and
never really gets the attention it needs.
And race this country,
and parts of the world
too is built on that idea.
It is built on that separation.
And so there is an urgent
need to address race
like no other identity in my view.
And so that's my perspective
on race and racism in
light of these other isms
that we are trying to address.
The issue of...
I'm blanking on the other question now.
(indistinct)
All right.
I will say very quickly (chuckles)
that I can't say a whole lot about that
because I'm on this National
Academies Committee,
that's looking at that,
and we can't say much
of people here have been
on National Academies here.
(Brandon laughs)
You're vowed to secrecy.
So we're beginning that work.
But I can say that,
and the committee is comprised
of social scientists,
epidemiologists, historians,
geneticists, and others.
I think in the next 10 years, we will see,
at least I hope we will see a shift in
how genetic studies are done
in light of what we know about race.
And I think if we see a
shift in genetic studies
that will inform what happens
in biomedical research at large.
I think genetics and the
role that genetics plays
in the creation of race
and the maintenance of this notion race.
I think if genetics and geneticists
and genomicists change
the way they do research,
and when I say change, I'm
talking about everything from
whether we use race or not,
but how we think about the role of genes
in outcomes, health, outcomes, traits,
whatever the outcomes are,
how geneticists think about
and design their studies,
I think will inform what
other disciplines do.
What I think a change is on the horizon.
I hope it is. (laughs)
- Great. Well, join me in congratulating.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(indistinct)
(table bangs)
I have so much talk to you about.
Please be my friend.